[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want and today we have
Jenna Jimenez here she's an actress
a comedian and a badass she's awesome
but first a word from two of our awesome
sponsors because they keep JK news alive
thank you very much money
the first one is upstart so upstart is
the first artificial intelligence
lending platform designed to improve
affordable credit so if you got bad
credit
you fix it just go up start goes beyond
the traditional FICO score win assess
when assist when assessing your
creditworthiness they reward you based
on your education and job history in the
form of a smarter interest rate that's
wrong yeah upstart believes you're more
than just your credit score they believe
in you and they understand that
so they care about the person not the
credit score they make it fast simple
and easy to check your rate in just a
few minutes without affecting your
credit score I think that's a big one
that's good for people with bad credit
they don't need another hit another
inquiry the best part once the loan is
approved most people get their funds in
the very next business day
the next day that's crazy
that's really fast so over 200,000
people have used up start to pay off
credit cards student loans fund their
wedding or to make a large purchase
maybe a car I don't know free yourself
from the burden of high interest credit
card debt by consolidating everything
into one monthly payment with up start
now see why upstart is ranked number one
in their category with over 300
businesses on Trustpilot and herida up
start comp slash record to find out how
low your up start rate is check in your
rate only takes a few minutes and won't
affect your credit what's that website
again upstart calm slash record oh thank
you fix your credit it is very important
do it you're not a credit fixer they're
a lender well you could make a
consolidate their loans and then fix
their credit if they need to
slam dunk it's about yeah it's about the
if you get it all done okay the next one
is Roman I really like Roman because
erectile dysfunction is more common than
you think
52% of men over 40 experienced erectile
dysfunction at some point and even worse
about 75 of those 75 percent of those
guys don't seek treatment
that's why Roman has made it easy to
chat with a doctor online see I need
this I need to talk to a doctor you're
getting really close to 40 you know that
right I am in five more years I might
have a really limp dick my dick isn't
hard like it used to be yeah and that's
not that's no laughing matter
yes funny you can go to chat with a
doctor online it is a hard matter so
with Roman you can get medical care for
Edie if appropriate from the comfort and
privacy of your own home that is the
cool part cuz then I don't have to feel
embarrassed and go to my doctor and then
like while he's checking my balls I'm
like hey you know can you check if I'm
you know like just see if I can get hard
yeah it's kind of weird okay you can
handle everything online in a convenient
discreet manner getting started is
simple just go to get Roman dot-com
slash OTR and complete an online visit
if your doctor decides that treatment
would be appropriate they can prescribe
genuine medication that can be delivered
in discreet packaging right to your
front door with free two-day shipping
hey Mia that's pretty fast what's that
website again so erectile dysfunction
can be tough to tackle but it's really
important to get checked out with Roman
it's easy to connect with the doctor so
yeah Roman calm slash OTR if you haven't
dick problems please please get it fixed
nice big stick and a nice fix credit yep
I want to know also like how do they
send it to discreetly does it look like
a pack of gum they set it up unmarked
box it comes in
boxes like yeah more obvious yeah I'm
late another bomb but I think that's one
that's super important and I wish that
people would talk about it like it was a
normal thing yeah because the more and
more I talked I mean I'm not forty but
the more and more I talked to my girls
they're like this limp-dick thing is a
real thing but there's so much shame
behind it yeah and it's like oh if we
just talk about it you could just fix it
yep yeah true and the credit score thing
wish that would have existed along yes
both things need hard inquiries I want
to get to know how like we met you do
you met Joe did you meet her so I guess
so I was at Gilbert's birthday party
which all of you did not go to cuz
you're not Gilbert Crabb you didn't bite
me and girl Gilbert called me out in
that video he said Jess I don't know
about people from Texas now and I said
to him get invited I didn't get invited
[ __ ] I did I know Gilbert but I did not
get about him well I thought he invited
everyone yeah you're especially cool
thing a good but the coping is kalila
was there and so was Janet uh miss
Newman is here Jenna Jimenez what Jew
menaces yeah so you menace that's in my
head she's missing two minutes telling
you you're struggling with her first
name Jew man it's like Jew Menace that's
what happens all the time I mean I
looked at one of my best friend's cell
phones and in it from six years ago it
still says like Jenna Jimenez or
something and I was like do you know my
last name she was like honestly like not
exactly
[Laughter]
okay so Jenna's my first name and
Jimenez is a mixture I don't even know
how it happened it's been my Instagram
for seven years since I got Instagram
my last name is Jimenez right in Spanish
my mom is a Jew so a bagel shop owner
and a taco stand guy got together right
well really my dad swam here and my mom
was working at the same
draw and she lost an earring and then he
found it my comment did you really just
take it and he's like no no need for Rio
okay
so super unlikely in the time that they
met and everyone thought that they were
gonna fail because back then like a
brown and Hawaii it was like my mind
just rained I'll do that and they fell
in love when they met my mom didn't
speak a lick of Spanish my dad did not
speak English so he she just thought he
was sexy and he found her earring and
she was like you know so she was super
not into him oh this macho energy is
extra is way too much for me and my dad
kept asking her on dates and she was
like no thank you
how did he ask without English he just
come on the TARDIS I like do you want
date me by the way he still speaks like
you just went oh I'm happy you've been
here for so long it's it's called a
hamburger not a Burger King the whole
thing you just want it all know what I
mean it's a hamburger like humble gift
size in Spanish yeah hamburger is in
English it's very it's very easy and
have so many they're like ah go oh I
grew up in Chicago and yeah so he asked
her out many times and it wasn't until
she lost her earring and he found it why
but she was like I owe you a day yeah it
is a hard thing to find an earring it is
anyone ever find mine fuckin'-a I know I
always lose them and you never find them
I know you gotta be putting in more work
I live there give him this relationship
it's like right you can't your finding
any earrings or anything but like look
all the time I thought hey if you need
anything I go [ __ ] find it don't I
that's true if I'm like oh [ __ ] dude man
he gets me a glass of water he's already
on the way to the kitchen when you go
I'm I see this bull he's like so ready
to serve you
like you can feel you that's my love
language as it's not served though I
just care my chick that's it but your
brother but to her that's how she reads
your friends as well what are you
talking about because I'll be like have
you guys seen any knives and no one's
listening but you across the room so I'm
like thank you Steve
whatever man oh yeah you're just a pizza
seasoning
I just don't answer actively ignoring
them but I'm listening but that's worse
he's at least that's romantic Joe yep
wait what's the point of listening if
the person doesn't know then you're just
hearing it yeah I'm hearing it he's
really good at doing that I got all not
even that we don't even get that in my
heart that's what I'm doing okay
mmm she's like cuz I didn't hear that
that's cool so you're deaf speaks
English now I mean no he speaks English
my mom speaks fluent Spanish
perfect oh nice so she learned it for
for him yeah she listened to her soft
she took Spanish and then she she said
she always had the radio on in Spanish
the TV on in Spanish she always tried to
speak that occasion wait so what
happened on this day she was like no
thanks no thanks you found an earring
fine and then she's like everything's
gonna be Spanish yeah what what kind of
dick does your dad see that's a really
good question
the next day she started playing
mariachi and she opened it she was like
I gotta convert everything in my hip so
like did you grab like Mexican then and
you're like the culture in your home
well I just realized there's that wow I
thought I was seeing things but there is
a person on the fears of belly I wear
taped to our sea otter weird distraction
I realized something about your
childhood I was like whoa I ask deep
questions so we got a lot of [ __ ] going
on in here
there's a basketball player on the
ceiling that's what you never sticker
Annunaki Burt so Micah so growing up I
was raised culturally
both I wasn't raised very religious
either although Judaism is a religion
it's also hugely a culture so like I was
bought myths fun I didn't have a
quinceanera
cuz every just left everything up to me
like you have whatever you could have
both you could have had it you could
have had it all but I was like I went
just so many Kingston yet us growing up
and like that [ __ ] is we see [ __ ]
yeah wedding for yourself it is a whole
ass wedding and I was like I don't want
to wear like a princess dress and so we
know we grew up with Hanukkah we did
Christmas at my dad's family's house we
went to Mexico that's so sick all the
time um see you that eval you go you
choke on what what what do girls do at
Bar Mitzvah I did not do as a girl bro
Mitzvah I was only boys boy is Bar
Mitzvah girl is bot Mitzvah you do the
same thing you have it do the chair
thing that looks really fun that's I
think that's a wedding wedding yeah I
thought they did the chair thing too
I'll stand with you make it fun stuff
together cuz if you're judging continue
at us you know you're like that's a
wedding yeah so make sure you thought
that no so I had to learn Hebrew it was
a dedication I had to be going to Sunday
school read how to learn learn how to
read out of the Torah you're reading
freaking backwards and symbols and [ __ ]
and then and then I had to like perform
it and the whole time my mom was just in
the audience telling me to close my legs
I have such a hard time asking like this
Seema it's just not comfortable my dad
would always brought a pillow at me like
to like cover it
humming shorts like what the [ __ ] where
I'm in my pants do you ever do
birthright it did do birth I'll go to
Israel yeah so birthright is these the
this couple set up a fund for Jews who
were like under 26 years old because
they're like we know you're broke to go
to Israel for free I don't have all that
money bro a lot of money Jew gold I
don't know I know a lot of broke Jews
like I'm a broke-ass Jew that's cuz at
the Mexican side that's how broke-ass
Mexican side no we only say that because
there's a Mexican in the room I wouldn't
say that if there was no Mexican in the
room that would be racist mo but racism
say that either word is so curious to me
because racism means that you are like
against the race yeah and want to
degrade it I feel like stereotypical is
the word that people mean to us all the
time and they're like dude I want a
degree this race is some way well then
that's different but you have to be more
clear in your deep yeah I'm just
I was just wasn't born white so it
doesn't hurt right right and people
don't think I'm waiting so it's always
really interesting like then you get the
past so you always say is that like
racially Mexicans are wait
cuz like every time there's a census I'm
forced to pin one they're Latin so it's
not a Caucasian not ethnicities well
then you do biracial we claim you dip
your ethnicity my ethnicity is not
latina my ethnicity is Mexican and
wherever my dad's at my my dad is um
native Indian Mexican but so my race
would still be like biracial Athena and
Caucasian cuz I asked one the census
person and then they're like you have to
put white yeah it's not it's yet white
Carter
it's either non-hispanic or Hispanic
I think they're all lumped together
that's good whew it's crazy but they do
that I also like what was it I heard
today that black people weren't even
included in the census or Africans
weren't even clued in the census until
like 2017 or so wait seven yeah no 2007
oh man in the 2000s that's way too late
2010 Jewish people are like why people
but with a race card because they blend
in with the white people and then they
can do all the white people privilege
things and they said but then but then
when they get like something there's the
anti-semite card and I'm like you can't
have both that's not fair dude
anti-semitism is so real like I would
meet people I lived in Argentina when I
was and they didn't know they didn't
know that you know no yeah the
descendants of Nazis the ones that ran
away to Argentina exactly there are a
lot of Nazis in Argentina what people
some people say that in order to have
like protection or something the
governor of the Argentine government
agreed to let like on the low the Nazis
in and I believe that because there's so
many Jews there and so many Nazis and
like you can't say that you're Jewish
there and so I had this experiment where
I befriended I was 16 so that was like a
hundred years ago I befriended my
friends in school but specifically ones
I knew hated Jews yeah and like let me
go hang out with the white supremacist
yeah you have a swastika let's be
friends yeah and I mean people kids
would draw swastikas on their desks yeah
very nice you were there alone oh
because I'm a crazy person I had extreme
freedom when I was a kid and through my
mom because she's like a hippie Jew and
my dad is still I mean she married a
Mexican right he's still conservative my
mom was like it's your fault that she
doesn't speak Spanish well because my
dad didn't my dad spoke Spanish but I
think he was concerned that we weren't
going to
simile yeah or something so my Filipino
grandparents didn't want to speak any
Tagalog around the kids because they
were they wanted them to be American and
they wanted to be accepted as American
but do you find I was like a mixed-race
person that like you don't fit in in
either one because like I constantly get
my brown card taken away cuz are like
well you're half white and then but like
my white friends don't see me as white
so like I don't feel like I'm white
either so it's always just like this in
the middle and I don't really get why I
don't know I just don't really
understand like the whole I need this to
be an identity thing like it's just kind
of like what it is I feel that people
can identify what you are they don't
know what to call you
yeah it was like beautiful Filipinos are
like well you're not Filipino all the
way because you're only half and so like
you don't get to be part of us
you know it's like a weird pride thing
where I'm like what am i ruining your
experience I don't know that problem I'm
so pure race yeah like I was raised like
when we go to my dad's side like there
was like the punt pants ed and lumpia
and like yeah you know it was it was all
like very Filipino and then when I went
to my white side it was very white he
was mashed potatoes and [ __ ] me doing
a salads and stuff yeah the funny thing
about all this [ __ ] is the people in the
Philippines right now like I don't have
time for this [ __ ] I got to work the
American Filipinos that were born here
that they're like I'm full Filipino and
you're not you don't get to be you don't
get that a lot
I mean so many times people have been
like well [ __ ] them like you're not
white and that's the thing like I will
especially in acting I will never be
white yeah same
I will never yeah just because of the I
came out darker yeah if the star of the
show that are dark long darker than my
mom I'm saying like cuz my mom is extra
white like red cheeks like her white
yeah my mom was like she's the poster
she has dark hair but he's like white
with rosacea she's considered an all
right someone some Mary yeah
who me yeah your face yeah personal you
just represent yeah all right your
population this is your face yeah leave
doesn't get that since you don't have
blue eyes girls yeah they don't want my
receding hairline on the flagger enough
them but there's nothing wrong with the
whiteness either like I love it but I'm
saying with acting I am brown there is
nothing else that I will ever be and I
will never get called into a room in
there you could pass for India yes
Middle Eastern I could accept that now
that's not a thing now it's like if you
are not that say yes yeah I used to get
called in for latina all the time cuz
I'm [ __ ] brown and I'm not I don't
look Asian
and because Filipinos aren't your last
names down and then they'd be like you
know Spanish I'd be like no and they'll
be like well are you latina and I'm like
no actually and they're like bah you
can't play it then I almost got cast in
this latina project or like a whole
Latino project yeah and then they found
out that I wasn't latina by blood and so
they were like no but it didn't used to
be like that it used to be like if you
looked it you could play it you could
act it cuz that's our jobs as actors to
just act at the issue now with having
people being misrepresented and not
having enough representation in those
areas that's where it becomes unfair
that I think we'll get to a place where
it evens out yeah and people are like
yeah you could you could play whatever
the [ __ ] overcompensating right now
cuz of the lack of representation but
I'm like I'm less represented exactly
how many girls are there there's a rose
is a lesbian she's playing a bat woman
but because she's not Jewish or some
[ __ ] like that she's not allowed to play
that woman according to work people
Hilaire that man's Jewish
I guess that woman is some Jewish person
not crazy so it's like no sorry
[ __ ] you you never got to hurt here her
white supremacist in Argentina story
I forgot okay oh yeah you keep
interrupting you guys did the rest
children tell them no so I became
friends with this guy specifically who
had always told me like basically the
Jews suck and like and I would all be
like oh do you do you know any we're not
gonna gonna like I know one I'm like
okay and also he had a thing about black
people and in Argentina there are no
black people damn there's maybe two
Africans how do you hate black people
when they're not around to bother you
well that's the thing though when you
don't know us yeah if you don't have
them around you yeah you become us
you're storing afraid Oh Jan
uncomfortable that actually makes more
sense yeah it comes from like you do it
that's like me saying like ah hate
Madagascar people [ __ ] them [ __ ] [ __ ]
them Turtles yeah some hard back yeah
those [ __ ] arctic penguins [ __ ] them
yeah it's they don't even do not even
around me how do you even make something
up about them so after about eight
months it was great because I was by the
way I forgot to say this Argentine man
which by the way if he came here more he
would be a minority I think they're like
white European and white but they're
like the runts of Europeans don't like
yours don't consider Argentinians like
no yes but there's a lot of Germans
Italians oddish it and well who's gonna
break the news to them you keep
interrupting the story Joe it's so
interesting cuz it's like when people
want him to opine he doesn't yes unless
you're like hold on I have a story to
tell he's like I'm just like you even
played instruments I'd be your hype man
I'm adding to you yeah I don't have an
issue with being interrupted cuz I
forget that I was talking and I helped
you out and I bought you in we know you
literally brought the story back I mean
look at what we're talking about now he
help you up
look at all these people oh my god do
you want to find out yes so this is the
thing that was really insane and
interesting is that he's gay Oh so but
he was out out gay also Nazi Jew hater
and at the end of my trip I had like two
weeks left with the end of my stay I was
like so I'm a super interesting I am
Jewish and he was like nah boy I said
and I was like no ya know my mom is a
big white Jew and he it was cool he took
a moment and he took weeks where he then
stopped denying it and was like I don't
know I guess I just like never I didn't
I didn't know anyone and I'm like that's
cool that's fine like I don't hate you
and you've proven to yourself that you
don't hate Jews because you love me yep
and that's that Menace oh hey no wait
real quick can you go like this anything
yeah I guess it is identity though yeah
you [ __ ] his whole identity that's
like that whole [ __ ] stereotype that
Jew eating in there like there's no way
you're not a Jew I left a gold coin next
to you and you didn't take it yeah they
just expect that whole [ __ ] thing
that they never met
[Music]